pas de télé pas celle-là qui était vide on
doit utiliser la grosse je t'ai dit de ne pas
mettre de métal dans la science oh ne fais pas
ça car c'est tellement grave je vais juste en
prendre une autre m'a donné le temps de commenter oh
pourquoi  ne vous contentez pas d'épouser le karma prenez un
petit micro-onde en or et mettez-le sur une
chaîne autour de votre cou vous voulez être
plus comme le carmin pourquoi ne construisez-vous pas
quelque chose comme lui au lieu de toutes
vos offres vides c'est juste comme votre
[ __ ] de science  four vous savez j'ai lu
qu'il enlève toute la nutrition
de notre nourriture c'est vide tout comme vos
offres conneries vides vides ce n'est pas des
conneries je l'ai lu dans un article regarde je
Paul oiseau ou apporte quelque chose dans cette
maison ça va prendre toute la nutrition
de notre nourriture et ensuite allumer notre maison
en feu Dieu merci pour moi